مخيم الزعتري اكبر مخيمات اللاجئين
السوريين في الصحراء الاردنيه يعيش سكره
اليوم رمضانهم الحادي عشر دون ان يلوح في
الافق اي حل سياسي لانهاء ماساتهم
اكثر من ثمانين الف سوري في المخيم يعيشوا
معظمهم ظلمه فرضتها سنوات اللجوء الطويله
تعيش ام ابراهيم مع ولدها في بيت من
الصفيح بارد في الشتاء وحار في الصيف
تحرقها نار الشوق الى سنوات قضت فيها
رمضان بمدينتها درعا والى بقيه عائلتها
التي شردتها الحرب
برمضان يوم كنا بسوريا كنا نجتمع سفره
وحده الاخرى البنات الخوات الاهل الاحبه
يعني هون لقيت اني في يعني في فرق كبير
يعني هون بحالك بحالك يعني
في كل زاويه قصه ووجع تتنازع المسن ابا
محمد ذكريات ثقيله لقد انهكته الحرب
وافقدته خمسه من اولاده
ورغم ذلك يامل ان ياتي رمضان المقبل وقد
عاد الى قريته ومنزله
م بشار كتلهم بشار
تغيبوا مظاهر الاحتفاء بالشهر الكريم عن
شوارع المخيم وسوقه فلدى السكان همومهم
التي تشغلهم
لكن بعض الطقوس تظهر في محاوله للتاقلم مع
الامر الواقع الاقب
ال نوعه
صعبه العصائر الرمضانيه حاضره رمضان ياتي
واخر ينقضي واحوال سكان الزعتري تراوح
مكانها شطف عيشا ونقص مساعدات واغتراب
قصري لكنهم ياملون في ايجاد حل ينقله من
مخيمه من الصحراوي الى ديارهم التي يحنون
اليها بعيدا عن الحرب تمر صمادي الجزيره
مخيم الزعتري